We have a voicemail number.
That number is 2 1 9 2.
David P..
Here is a caller who.
Well, I'll just let her say it.
I don't need to tell you too much about it.
Take a listen.
Hey, David.
Just watch the video about Trump tweeting
over 50000 times in one hour and was very
much reminded of my own brother in law before
she was officially filed.
Masked, asked for months more to call family
members.
Up to 100 times a day, leaving voicemails
or talking to them because she literally forgot
that she had called us and part of me in this.
Absolutely.
And this would be horrible.
But it really reminds me of that.
And it makes me think that this could possibly
be a sign of dementia, that she's not remembering
all these tweets that she's given within an
hour.
And it just really reminds me of that.
Thanks so much.
Yeah.
So, I mean, of course, you know, I'm not qualified
to say anything about a dementia diagnosis,
but what you're talking about with memory
is interesting.
And there's a couple of things I would I would
put out there, number one.
There are times when reporters, quote, Trump's
own tweets to him and he certainly doesn't
seem to remember them.
His answer doesn't indicate he actually remembers
the content of the tweet, but that just may
be how Trump answers questions.
OK, that's one thing.
There are reports from people inside the White
House not authorized to speak about this that
say Trump doesn't remember.
He just doesn't remember.
He doesn't remember conversations he's had
with people.
He essentially arguing that one of the explanations
that maybe is not getting enough attention
when Trump appears to be lying or saying that
he didn't say something that he's on record
saying is that he genuinely has no memory
of it.
So this is not the first time that such an
allegation has been made.
On today's bonus show, very exciting.
I am going to give you a prepping update.
I have a number here in my home studio.
I have received via the mail a number of elements
of prepping that I've ordered, some which
are obviously beneficial, some which I have
questions about.
So I'm going to talk about that a little bit
on today's bonus show.
We will also talk about 2000 former Department
of Justice and FBI officials who are calling
on William Barr to resign for his handling
of the Michael Flynn case.
We will talk about murder Hornets, so-called.
And we will also talk about the Supreme Court
appearing as though they are going to give
religious employers a pretty broad based ability
to discriminate.
All of those stories and more on today's bonus
show get instant access by signing up at join
Packman dot com or by making a pledge of at
least five bucks a month at Patry on dot com
slash David Pakman show.
We'll see you on the bonus show or on the
livestreams or on tomorrow's program.
Appreciate you joining me today.